as [ __ ] ass has bad words hmm hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua fields Milburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalists today we're going to talk
about consciousness we're gonna talk
about the mysteries of the brain we're
gonna talk about decluttering our minds
with today's guest Annika Harris is here
she's the altar woman oh she's author of
a new book conscious a brief guide to
the fundamental mystery of the mind if
you're watching this on YouTube I'll
hold it up here I love that cover by the
way tell me did you design that or it
was that Gemma
O'Brien is the brilliant artist who did
this these illustrations and I was very
lucky to be able to work with her but I
knew I knew that the cover was going to
be important for this I really wanted
this to be an accessible book on a topic
that is largely confined to academic
circles and so I knew the artwork on the
cover would would matter and she she
totally nailed it
well it turns out with this book you can
judge a book by its cover it's an
amazing cover and it's an amazing book
her cover was going to raise the
expectations too high reader could only
be disappointed after that cutter what's
this is someone to write a book about
consciousness I mean what is next like
quantum physics and by the way turning
it into something that is like there's a
certain amount of brevity here and it's
the same but it's also it's palatable
because like as you said it's it's
generally a topic that is just argued
about within academia and 13 people
might read a book about that but you've
you've written something that is
accessible but it also left me walking
away with more questions than answers
but I feel like that was your attention
I actually originally had a series of
questions at the end just to kind of
reiterate these are all the questions
that I think are interesting and that we
need to be thinking about and we decided
not to include them but the book is
itself a series of questions really and
it's more than anything it's about
challenging our intuitions and about
that being an important piece of the
scientific
process so I did you want me to give a
little the book is yeah so yeah it's
about the the science and philosophy of
consciousness and I really wanted there
to be an accessible book on the topic
it's something that I have thought about
my whole life I've been basically
obsessed with thinking about this topic
and then for the last twelve or so years
I've been working primarily with
neuroscientists but with scientists in
general and so I've learned more about
the brain through my work with with
scientists and I started actually
writing to work through some of my own
thoughts it was really my own notes that
and they started probably 12 years ago
and actually around that time I tried to
get some other academics who I worked
with to write a book like this and I
couldn't convince anyone to do it yeah
well I didn't know that's how it would
go but um after many many years of
thinking about it and reading and
researching and interviewing scientists
I I just felt like I needed to work
through my own ideas and it's such a
complex topic that I just started
writing my own notes and sharing with
friends and a few of them suggested that
I that actually published something so
it's started I actually started writing
a long article that I thought it would
go to you know Scientific American or
something like that and the more I
shared it with people the more people
started suggesting that I actually
turned it into a book so I didn't I'm
not sure but sure I ever would have
taken on this project if I'd known what
I was getting myself into but yeah so so
it is I take the reader through what I
think are some of the most interesting
theories and research in consciousness
studies and it really focuses on what
makes consciousness so mysterious and
why it's continuing to dumbfound
scientists and why it's so difficult for
scientists to study but it's really all
of all of the work that I discuss is
really in the context of challenging our
intuitions about what consciousness is
and that being an important part of the
project especially when we're stuck on
something so this is true in every
area of knowledge and scientific
breakthrough it seems that in order to
understand something at a more
fundamental level to understand a more
fundamental truth it requires that we
challenge at the very least challenge
our intuitions often we have to
completely let go of some intuitions
that were totally misleading us and I
always like to give examples here
because it sounds right but people don't
realize that this is basically true of
every scientific breakthrough we've had
you know starting with understanding
that the earth is a sphere and not flat
as all of our senses lead us to believe
- anything that happens on a significant
timescale evolution the the idea that I
am somehow related to fish or mushrooms
or banana yeah that we shared genes I
mean these are counterintuitive facts
the germ theory of disease was something
that took human beings a very long time
to get their heads around see mystical
and even now without science still seems
mystical know what we we don't have
intuitions for it right we can't see we
can't see it we can't feel it we have no
way with our with our everyday senses to
perceive these microscopic organisms and
so something that's totally invisible to
us makes us sick and can kill us you
know this is not something we have
intuitions for so I think when we're
stuck in an area of knowledge or
scientific something that we're
interested in studying scientifically I
think the first step or one of the steps
has to be challenging our intuitions and
so I think we're at a point like that
with consciousness right now that's what
I really like about your book is you do
an excellent job of helping the reader
let go of intuitions whether it's with
you know scientific data or just the
different lenses that you put in the
book like you know you talked about if
you and your friend could join brains
and like what would that consciousness
look like but just a simplified
experiment like that totally I think
helps you like oh that intuition so yeah
excellent work excellent job well today
we're going to talk about some different
types of consciousness I think and
because even that word is you
used to mean different things at
different time actually I made this
mistaken in another interview where I
forgot to define it and then at the end
of the conversation it would have been
helpful sometimes people mean awareness
right they just mean what what do people
mean and what do you would how do you
define consciousness consciousness has a
wide range of definition people use it
to mean many different things which is
so it makes it confusing and I start
with a definition in the book what I'm
talking about in the book and usually
what philosophers and scientists are
referring to when we're talking about
the most fundamental level of
consciousness so some people use the
word consciousness to to talk about
self-awareness or thinking or complex
thought but what I'm talking about in
the book and what is is in fact a
mystery is a much more fundamental the
basic sense of an experience and
actually think experience is a better
word awareness has multiple definitions
- and doesn't necessarily entail
consciousness and we can kind of go
through those but so consciousness the
way I use it in the book I actually
bring up the philosopher Thomas Nagle's
description that he uses in his his
famous essay you're both shaking your
heads I feel like you've read this essay
what it what is it like to be a bat and
in that essay he says an organism is
conscious if there's something that it's
like to be that organism for some people
they get that invent that's has a strong
meaning for other people they can't get
their mind around that language which
makes sense to me because the language
is not really precise yeah it's more
kind of getting at a sense of experience
so I only the latter like it took me
yeah reading that a couple times
really underside I think most people are
in that camp for sure especially it's
not actually accurate language what it's
like so I in the book and in
conversation with people I'll say is
there something that it's like to be you
right now and of course you immediately
you know that conjures up the fact that
you're having an experience there's your
your collection of matter in the
universe and that matter is having an
experience is there something that it's
like to be
that glass of water and our answer is no
you know we imagine there's no
experience there and even if we're wrong
it doesn't actually matter the point is
if you can distinguish between a
collection of matter in the universe
that doesn't have experience and one
that does that differences consciousness
so at a very basic level it doesn't
necessarily entail thoughts or awareness
or its yeah just a pure pure experience
yeah I think experience is a good a good
word to kind of help to find what we're
talking about here well your book left
me with a lot of questions and we've got
some questions from our audience today
so I think we'll start with those our
first one is from Marco in Flagstaff how
do you mentally minimalize your how much
you think I guess you could say I'm kind
of having an issue with just
decluttering my thought process and
thinking and I've physically decluttered
much of my things but now problem for me
comes to mentally decluttering and I was
asking if you guys had any message or
things that could help with that
so Salonika the this question tends to
come up a lot it manifests differently
but we have cluttered minds
whatever that means one of the most
difficult parts of consciousness is when
we our brain is running amuck yeah
there's a David Foster Wallace story
called forever overhead and it's about a
13 year old boy on his 13th birthday and
he is out of swimming pool going up to
the high dive for the first time and it
is it's beautiful story but the whole
story is about thinking and how he's
trying to stop thinking and how that
leads to more thinking and there's a
line in there I'm paraphrasing
but you have decided that most fear
comes from thinking and I think it's so
true all of our sort of well I mean of
course everything here has to do with
thinking but how do we compare that to
to consciousness because I think well in
a little bit we might dive in the pan
psychism and I was actually pleasantly
surprised to see that in here
not because I necessarily believe in it
but because you were totally open to it
yeah I don't necessarily believe in it
either in the book I say I'm I'm 50/50
whether you know there's a brain-based
explanation for consciousness or whether
it actually goes it goes deeper than
that I think that's another one of the
tools that you use to kind of help let
go of those intuitions that we have so
pants.i chasm basically means everything
is conscious am i describing that
correctly like this microphone to say
that I think is misleading but I'm okay
pants like ism is a category of theories
that describe consciousness as being a
fundamental feature of the universe and
it ranges from theory to theory whether
that's at information processing or
exists in some sort of field the
fluctuations of which you know give
matter this intrinsic property of
experience
yeah often so one of the criticisms
often is and it's I have to always say
it sounds completely crazy it sounded
crazy to me for a very long time well
there are years where I just didn't
really even look into it because it
sounded so out there yeah and it just
it's the way everything's connected man
yeah I mean there are there are a lot of
New Age
New Age thinking that likes to adopt pan
psychism to help support whatever you
know pseudo scientific theory sometimes
come up with and most often that's not
actually it's not something that can be
applied to this you know any crazy ideas
that I forget actually which jokes I
used in my book but I think one was you
know if your neighbor thinks she can
talk to her ficus or you know those
types of things pan psychism does not
actually make any of those claims and
doesn't support those claims
so yeah the idea that the microphone is
conscious I mean just to say it's a
label an inanimate object and say you
know it's conscious one we have to be
very careful to distinguish
consciousness from complex thought so
that's where Marko is right now we
assume Marko has a brain in his head
right and and so I guess that the the
two sides here one span psychism all
matter has some sort of consciousness is
the theory there whether or not
and then the other is that consciousness
emanates from the brain yes and so with
with Marco it seems like okay he's he's
really struggling with with his thoughts
now of course my first inclination is
say well have you ever meditated right
but it's like literally the first thing
I had written down - can we give them
something it's cliche advice but like
cliches are cliches for a reason but
meditation totally does help quiet the
mind it helps you to deal with those
thoughts because those thoughts are
always going to enter your mind the
question is like how are you going to
deal with those thoughts right so it
does kind of paradoxically have the
effect of quieting your mind just
becoming aware of the thoughts usually
not always but know what meditation
gives you is the ability to be with
whatever is in your mind without this
this struggle without this conflict
without feeling like there's all this
clutter right it's almost like the
minimalist approach to to clearing your
thoughts is more just to let them be
there there's something there's
something simpler about letting them be
there rather than trying to block
wrestling yeah we're so overstimulated
right now as well I often say when it
comes to the physical goods the easiest
way to get rid of them is not bring them
in in the first place
and and I think also if you're someone
like Marco or
like most of us who deals with anxiety
or or we just have so many discrete bits
of input that are being barrage it's
drinking from from the fire hose and
maybe the first thing to do is to turn
the volume down externally as well so
we're exposing ourselves to you know the
thing that's vibrating in our pocket or
the computer screen in front of us in
the television and sometimes we're doing
all three at once and of course that's
going to lead to a clutter mind so I
think that that also reducing the number
of inputs
makes it a bit I'm also easier but
simpler to sort of sit with those
thoughts because no matter what you can
remove all the inputs go do a 30 day
retreat in a cave you're still going to
have the thoughts yes and that yeah and
I think that really speaks to his
question because from the beginning of
humanity
when we had almost nothing right when we
weren't the rumination and thoughts kind
of pushing you around and causing
uncomfortable psychological states is
just I mean it's essentially the human
condition so language is sort of a
precursor to that and if before humans
had language maybe we had fewer
anxiety-producing thoughts mmm well I
mean we definitely yes I think so I mean
it's all it's all brain processing right
and then whatever I mean even in some
crazy world where pen psychism is true
that doesn't actually change anything we
already know which is that this
collection of matter which is my brain
is processing and doing its thing and
that gives rise to the experience I'm
having right that's why my experience is
different from a cat's experience or you
know it's it's the processing and so I
think sometimes these types of questions
get framed incorrectly in the way I like
to think about I think what's important
to remember is it is all brain
processing and then how does that brain
processing change or become influenced
or get affected because our brains are
not these closed off systems they're
constantly interacting with the outside
world through our senses but also now
that we have language through through
thoughts and communication so you can
affect a brain purely in a physical
sense by through medication or you know
and drugs or surgery or injury you know
any way in which the physical brain is
manipulated will actually change your
experience because the brain is changing
but thoughts and communication also
change and so we we tend to think of
those as as as if the end result is
different but the end result is the same
so if I if I you know look freaked out
and said oh my god someone just walked
into the room with a gun you're you
would have a whole physiological
response to that right like that that
idea actually changes your your brain
and changes your physical being even if
it was true you just said it and I
believed it that would be enough to
change my physiology yeah right and so
this is happening all the time ideas
thoughts that we're having ourselves or
the
ideas that our own brain comes up with
is there's like this feedback loop right
where then affects the physical state of
the brain other people's ideas affect
the physical state of our brain and then
there's you know jeans and everything in
the environment and everything else
that's affecting it but then the end
result is what we're experiencing and so
when we're looking to change our
experience the question is always what's
the best way to change the state of my
brain and it can sometimes be through
thoughts or through meditate techniques
techniques of meditation and it can be
through so maybe it's like how do you
break that feedback loop so yeah
meditation would help I always say to
Lake there it's for me it's always
important to have a good therapist on
hand because I can go and talk stuff out
and I have you know client privilege
where you know he can't repeat what I'm
saying
I'm Tony Soprano like totally made it
okay for me to go see a therapist I'm
like you know I like he goes and he goes
and has people deal with his [ __ ] like
I'm gonna go and have someone deal with
my [ __ ] but but you know even if it's
not a therapist it could be a friend
that you're talking stuff through with
it could even be a book that you read to
kinda help you gain a different
perspective so Marco I mean there are
many tools here that we've brought up
it's it is a matter of you know trying
each tool out and seeing what works best
for you there isn't going to be a
catch-all magic bullet answer although I
think meditation probably could be no I
think it's the best answer for sure
another one I just thought of though is
that when we get into kind of repetitive
thinking or we can't really stop
ourselves we get kind of into these
grooves of thought processes of anxiety
or whatever it is just stopping that
cycle for a moment actually makes a
difference physiologically too so
changing your zone yes yeah and that can
be done I mean that's part of the reason
why I love listening to podcasts now it
gives you a break from your own thought
cycles so listening to a podcast
listening to an audiobook reading a book
getting yourself engaged in something
that just it just breaks the cycle for a
minute can help you reset and I actually
think that's often for people who are
really ruminating and getting stuck in
anxious thoughts in
in particular but other types of
thinking like that where you can get
kind of caught up in a loop getting your
mind focused on something else before
you meditate I actually think it's very
helpful that way that way during the
meditation you're not just ruminating
about the problem well it'll come back
it'll come back but it's it's an easier
place just to start from yes indeed
mark Roman send you a copy of on ACCA's
book it's called conscious also I'd love
this in your copy of our book essential
it's an essay collection with 150 essays
in it twelve different chapters about
twelve different areas of intentional
living but one of those chapters is
about mindfulness so we'll send you both
of those a copy of conscious and a copy
of essential Shauna if you could reach
out to Marco I'd appreciate that send
him the audio book or or the book book
or the e-book if he would prefer Ryan
what time is it you know what time it is
it it's time for our lightning round
where we answer questions from social
media indeed we do so we're at the
minimalists on Facebook Twitter and
Instagram
during the lightning round on it goes
where we we we attempt to answer
questions with short shareable less than
hundred forty character responses what
you'll do is you'll just like kind of
you know give an answer ramble on a
little bit and then Sean will make it
nice and beautiful in post
yeah he'll make it tweetable he's the
best editor I know and we call these
minimal Maxim's we put the text in these
minimal Maxim's in the show notes so you
can copy and share our pithy answers on
social media if you like and you can
find all of our minimal Maxim's in one
place now thanks to our good friend
Jessica Lynn Williams minimal maximum
comm all right our first question is
from Sameer why does a spontaneous
purchase of an expensive thing make you
feel good now sir I just want to give
the caveat here that as being one of the
minimalists I still get that urge to buy
stuff and when I did for Chris I know
right and it's like even when I do make
well I guess you know kind of staving
off those impulses when I actually do
you make a purchase it makes it you know
a little bit more meaningful but I still
get that dopamine hit you know it's like
I don't think there's a you know this
magic bullet answer that's gonna like
make people stop wanting to buy
but but yeah it certainly is it can be
addicting for sure
well my pithy answer is then we can
unpack this a bit a fairy tale well told
doesn't make it more true and I mean I'm
looking at some years question here and
it's like does it make you feel good
maybe in the moment I think what Sameer
is doing is confusing pleasure with
contentment in a way and you get the
dopamine rush you get the the the the
the checkout line high so to speak but
that doesn't last far past the checkout
line it doesn't bring you real joy or
contentment as a minimalist everything I
own serves a purpose or brings me joy I
like to say but very few things actually
bring me joy Josh is allergic to joy no
I I find the things that bring me joy
rarely are things you could tweet that
podcast shot but there is that there has
to be a process in the brain right
there's there's some dopamine being
released here too so I was thinking
about this I was thinking about this
watching your documentary because I
relate to a lot of it and in many ways I
am a minimalist and I just that that's
how I've always been
but you would laugh my closet after
hearing that statement but I think for
sure
Oh many more things bring me joy than
bring you joy right so every not
everyone is the same just at a base
level absolutely yeah so yeah I mean I
think that distinction is important but
I think yeah what you said is absolutely
true that it gives you kind of a high in
the moment and I think there's a
evolutionary reason for it to where
we're needing to collect things where
you know where we evolved to live in a
very different world from the world we
live in
yeah but we're still clinging while our
brain still clings to those those
imperatives so to speak way and that the
need to hoard was actually a useful one
at one point in time and now it just
sort of gets in the way of living a more
fulfilling life yeah I wish there was
like this list of 100 things I could be
like Anika here's 100 different pieces
of material items you need and this is
you're going to live a very
happy perfect life and no you're
absolutely right I mean that's Josh and
I stressed out a lot about how what we
talk about is what we do and even him
and I you know differ an opinion on some
things believe it or not but uh all
right so my pick the answer very similar
what I was talking about earlier with
the dopamine don't go chasing dopamine
the ephemeral pleasures are easy and
addictive so Shawn's gonna insert the
TLC so everything our next question is
from Drew
do you consider obsession over a person
place or thing to be a byproduct of a
diagnosable disorder or is obsession
just a state of mind well I have OCD and
so I guess that's a diagnosable disorder
I learned from your book that it's
probably because I like touch cat [ __ ]
when I was a kid I know it's
unbelievable like the stuff that you
bring up how plasmosis you change your
personality
OCD oh yes no that's strep the strep
bacteria and young children Oh
causes severe can cause severe OCD when
the body has this strange response to it
aha so so in August book she talks about
a couple different uh germs or bacteria
that can totally affect your
consciousness affect who you are what
your impulses are I mean there's a um
well I guess this doesn't really change
your consciousness but did you hear
about the something the mosquito or
something that like makes you or the
tick that makes you allergic to meat
yeah like yeah it's crazy deer tick
that's advanced I know I go into all
this detail about parasites which is the
most fascinating stuff where it just
completely takes over certain behaviors
of the host and so they have drives and
desires that they didn't have before
that are totally based on the parasites
needs right plus Moses is the one that
makes rat run toward cats and and it's
just it's changing their brain and I
think the same is true I mean for Drew's
question here
my pithy answer is simple its labels are
incomplete and limiting but necessary
and and so so I label this thing a
microphone right that's necessary we
have language that's a label right
but it's also when we label something
like you have obsessive-compulsive
disorder it becomes this limiting
diagnosis that is disempowering in a way
and so when a doctor told me when I was
in my early 20s that I have OCD is like
well I have this diagnosis but what does
that mean oh well now I just means I'm
I'm what track for the rest of my life I
mean there's a range and it's it's not
really a specific thing in the way that
they they label it as and I I tend to be
OCD and I've actually been diagnosed
with it but I I'm sure that you know I'm
on that spectrum somewhere and I
remember talking to someone about it at
some point I was asking quit was a I was
asking someone of questions about
psychiatry and the brain and these types
of things and he said most successful
people are on the OCD spectrum and so a
lot of these things that are
diagnoseable in a some lesser form
actually extremely useful and I'm sure
you have noticed all the ways in which
it's helped you in your life yeah it's
made me care about things and attention
to detail has been amplified and I mean
it's these are all like descriptions of
your personality and the way your brain
works and in combination with the things
you've been through in your life and
yeah I think OCD is not the most helpful
way to describe all of these different
but that is I mean it's it's definitely
again I would go back to kind of looking
at the brain as a system and how if
you're if you're uncomfortable right if
you're in a in experiencing the types of
things people experience with OCD and a
very extreme way this can totally limit
your life they can it can be
debilitating it can be you could it can
make you very unhappy so the question is
what's the best way to change the state
of your brain and there are different
responses to that and meditation is one
and medication is another and they're
both valid and it kind of varies from
person to person but I think it's it's
good for someone to recognize that
they're suffering in that way if they're
suffering so that they can make it
change yeah absolutely I mean that kind
of leads into my pithy answer which is
extremes
be a detriment so you know with Josh's
OCD for example it could be a detriment
if he like let it go to the extreme but
he has tools and different things that
he uses to well like you said Annika to
like use it kind of as this like secret
power that really helps Josh with his
life but you know anything that we
obsess over if we get to that terminus
of obsession I think when you get to
that terminus it will always be a
detriment so when it comes to obsession
it's just really about deciding what is
the balance and then once you can kind
of see where the balance is like how do
you get there I hopefully love a healthy
healthy level of obsession has helped me
do some really powerful things like
writing a book I don't think you can
write a book without a healthy level of
obsession yeah I'm sure you were you you
stayed obsessed about this especially to
get it as as pithy right but it's also
not you know Infinite Jest in the sense
of its length like you could it's like a
phone book but this is like the this is
distilling it down into again I like I
said I walked away with a bunch of
questions
yeah those questions I think were were
helpful it wasn't just like why didn't
she answer I mean again part of my OCD
would be like I want the answers to
positive she didn't tell me exactly what
it is - but I think boner we're gonna
get there's to ask more questions ya
know ultimately I feel the same way I
just want to know which is why I can't
stop thinking about it I think and it
would be disingenuous for you to posit a
well here is the explanation right many
people have tried to do that right and
and what I like about it is you present
some different points of view and you
bring them forward in a way where it's
they can battle with each other or they
might battle each other and in my own
mind and we think we walk away with with
a better understanding but in a weird
way a less complete understanding but
realize I was writing this for the
general public the main reason I wanted
to write it initially was because we
actually get a lot of joy and
we enjoy the experience of feeling awe
and encountering things that we can
wonder about and there's actually
research a lot of research on this now
actually and it increases our well-being
to have things that inspire awe and most
people are immediately interested when
they hear there's new information about
black holes or about you know the
beginnings of the universe or about
everything that comes out of quantum
physics it's all just perplexing and
incredible and we like to think about it
it's fun to think about it they're done
you know endless documentaries and books
and for me consciousness fits in with
those great mysteries for sure and so I
really just wanted I mean as much as I
want to actually understand it and it's
true with all these things I want to
understand you know is there beginning
to the universe and these things like
infinity I was actually just talking
about this there's a great children's
book called infinity and me and it's
just about wrestling with this idea that
we can't actually get our minds around
it right something that goes on forever
we can't imagine it but if we am at we
can't imagine an end either right so I
think these things actually bring us joy
and I think many people don't realize
how mysterious consciousness is and how
yeah I knew it was it was something I
didn't have a grasp on but now I sort of
understand why I don't it's like a great
mystery that we can all think about and
contemplate and be awestruck by yeah and
appreciate it anyway all right looks
like we have a bunch more surprise
questions this week how do I hold my
minds obsession with purging stuff
how has your study of consciousness
affected your worldview and priorities
in life that should be an interesting
one what does it mean to live a
meaningful life also uh Annika is gonna
explain to us why freewill doesn't exist
and why that's okay and and much much
more if there's time let's discuss
meditation for kids my daughter just
turned six you have a mindful games
which we'll talk about I haven't played
that with Ella yet but I have read your
children's book all I wonder yeah and
we're going to we can talk about that a
little bit too and if you want to hear
all that you can listen to this week's
maximo episode available exclusively on
patreon that's right you're currently
listening to our weekly minimal episode
but each week Ryan and I and Annika this
week
we record a much longer maximal episode
on the minimalists private podcast which
gives us the private space we need to
talk about a bunch of stuff we don't
talk about in public this week we talked
about ketamine and much much much much
more anyway a patreon is also the best
way for us to fund this podcast keep it
a hundred percent advertisement free so
thank you to our patreon supporters when
you subscribe to our minimalist podcast
to the private podcast on patreon you'll
also receive a personal link so that our
maximal episodes play in your favorite
podcast app you can find all the details
and all the good stuff including an
additional pot a private podcast episode
every week over at the minimalists com
slash support it's also worth noting
that we're capping our patreon
supporters at 6000 supporters so we're
more than halfway there now and we've
more than doubled in the last few months
so if you're interested now is a good
time to to get on board and listen to
the private podcast that we do every
week Ryan what else you got for us being
informed is more important than ever as
always I want to encourage people to
read more and get informed that reminds
me of this cartoon Ryan oh yeah yeah
it's from The New Yorker it's two guys
seated at a dinner table together and of
course they're just talking about
whatever and the guy says and don't even
get me started on topics I even know
less about that's how I feel that's what
I felt today about talking about
consciousness it was a fun conversation
though all right man hey I've got some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners check them out high minimalist
this is Katie from Anglesey in Wales in
the UK and I just wanted to share a
resource that's helping me use Instagram
in a more minimalist and deliberate way
it's called filter grab and the website
is filter gram app and the way it works
is you add people that you want to
follow by their Instagram usernames and
then it shows your feed on filter gram
in chronological order with no comments
other than the initial caption and
hashtags and crucially no advertisements
it's read-only but if you do want to
interact with a post you can easily open
it on Instagram it was one click you can
also add keyword filters so you just
display certain content from the people
that you follow for example if you only
want to
posts from a specific user that
mentioned minimalism is web-based so
there's nothing to install on your
computer or your phone and you also
don't even need an Instagram account to
use it so I hope this is useful for
people who like Instagram and want to
connect with people but want to do so in
a bit more of a deliberate way this is
Chantel from Anchorage Alaska I have a
tip for listeners who are on their
journey towards becoming minimalist with
their belongings but struggle with guilt
from getting rid of items whether it's
guilt from the wasted money spent or the
emotional attachment to items you are
ready to part with it could sometimes be
difficult to just dump certain items
into a box and donate them to a thrift
store without seeing them appreciated by
somebody else instead check out your
community's Facebook groups such as pay
it forward or by noting which allows you
to post an item online and people in
your community can respond to claim the
item then you meet up to hand the item
off it requires a little more time
investment but that allows you to
contribute to someone who may be in need
and to see that the item will truly be
valued by another person and put to good
use
rather than sorted through by a
for-profit thrift store and you never
know if it's actually going to make it
to someone else's hands it helps to
reduce waste and consumerism it makes
you feel like you're contributing while
also helping you clear your own space of
things you no longer use I've been a
member of both pay it forward and buy
nothing for years and it's been very
useful to get rid of things and also
acquire things that I know will be put
to good use without going out and
spending money alright Joe thanks again
to annika harris for joining us today
you can check her out at Annika Harris
comm check out her new book it's called
conscious you can get that wherever
wherever books are sold also she's a
great kids book that I read to Ella all
the time it's called I wonder I'll hold
this up for the YouTube audience here
and I haven't played these with Ella yet
but I'm going to
mindful games activity cards which she
co-produced with Susan Kaiser Greenland
so you can check those out we'll put a
link to those in the show notes is well
all in real quick four right here right
now here's one thing that's going on in
the life of the minimalists Jordan we
having one of those coffee bags that
just gave one to Annika on her way out
but Ryan and I opened the coffee shop a
few he give me
the pretty purple one we opened a coffee
shop a few years ago we just started
roasting coffee a couple years ago and
now it's available to the public for the
first time very recently and if you're
interested we do this thing called the
minimalist choice it's what Ryan and I
are drinking currently this isn't the
actual one but that's going on right now
but if you just go to the minimalists
dot coffee na komm you can go to the
minimalist comm they'll take you to our
website but if you want to go to our
coffee
it's the minimalists dot coffee is the
extension there and you can find out
what we're drinking right now you can
order it yourself so you don't actually
have to go to st. Petersburg Florida
anymore yeah in order to drink our
favorite coffee I'm really proud of this
new packaging - beautiful he did such a
great job just the attention to detail
that those guys give a bandit is just
it's incredible man from the packaging
to the amazing freakin coffee that
they're producing right now amen
so I check that out the minimalists dot
coffee if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
voicemail 4 0 6 2 1 9 7 8 3 9 or send a
voice memo to podcast at the minimalists
comm you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox you
can sign up for our email list over at
the minimalists comm you'll also receive
our simple Sunday emails each week for
our added value this week let's listen
to a song that sounds like consciousness
to me Ryan uh you know Jonesy from sigur
rós I mean I know sigur rós yeah so
Jonesy is the lead singer and he has an
album with his partner Alex and the
group is called Jonesy and Alex and the
album is called rice boy sleeps I
believe mm-hmm yeah yeah rice boy sleeps
and this song is called happiness it's
from Jonesy and Alex's 2009 album rice
boy sleeps and to me it just it sort of
sounds like what I imagined
consciousness sounds like if you were to
like I want to make a musical score for
consciousness it's this album and
especially this song that's great if you
were here today with just one message
y'all we hope it's this love people and
use things because the opposite never
works thanks for listening y'all we'll
see you next time minimus